righto good people here at the southern
fueled days and one moment we're at the
gore district councils sauce and I'll
tell you what goes one of the great
places regardless of what the people say
many things to offer and one of those is
the flushing now in they tell me that
you're the man to talk to you when it
comes to their area of expertise
yeah well thanks for that look come it's
a great place where you can laundry at
your back door and go down to the river
and catch yourself a feed and what
especially you catch it
brown trout here brand [ __ ]
predominantly in the matera River Seas I
am pretty hungry yeah well that's right
well you're probably quite in luck
tonight because I have already been down
the river we've all go that's what I
like beef before it got a bit dirty like
it is clearing at the moment but did
catch some and which makes mud would you
like to try weave it I'll tell you what
was gonna be stopped away alright well
people look you can't do better than us
and you know the real the real kicker is
you cannot boy this stuff and if you
really like it
get yourself a license get out to the
river commune and catch yourself for
fish and look what you can have I'll
tell you what that they're good people
is worth the price of admission alone
moonshine whiskey smoked trout illegal
and you can't boy you hit in Tennessee
that one
nothing better it's um it's one of the
secrets of Southland so yeah so far cop
next door can see that moonshine whiskey
absolutely right okay probably give you
a taste of that too buddy out sounds
good to me
champion okay peoples who are still down
here at the gore District Council team
to hit some ice cube tray off to tell
you what it was infused with the
moonshine whiskey so naturally you're
either think come and see what all the
fuss is about with this whiskey and I've
got Jim here who's the extraordinaire
the man to talk to when it comes to this
neck of the woods sir
you've got a whole range going on here
of this whiskey's yeah we know lace yes
she Poconos was almost Libre whiskey it
was always a grain spirit and because we
had extended years of prohibition
whiskey used to be in a barrel for
certainly at the time nobody was going
to keep
in the indian farm so what Tina they
happen was they would either to come
straight out of still young like that
which is essentially a grain spirit made
of barley and it's been watered down to
an acceptable level of fifty percent
alcohol by volume or else they'd off the
flavor in in this instance we've
flavored it with local honey but if
people want to get their hands on where
do they go to if they go to the Hakka
moonshine museum and war yep the front
of house was the corpus of cedar
okay I just appear the earth boy and we
go only in gold good people mergesort
out I can't have one by myself you're
gonna have to everyone with our yeah I
know what's in that so much that's we
have a good people you know we don't
like I'll seduce you do cheesie's no yep
right I got people that is not go
without a fly fishing at the fly-fishing
temple in the world I've gots to the
experts yeah I'm here to show me how
it's done so if you want more than happy
to show me the way then I'll try follow
suit what a team this is where it
happens this is a weeping a choice and
we're just gonna take this line here
check it straight over there like that
simple does that do that I'll give you a
chocolate fish enough right so it's just
a simple motion that is indeed yeah back
then fought back and forward so easy
just a bit more of that in Europe just
like that probably wit more than that
okay right excellent
don't know the expert already prep the
gore is aa trip with that flossing and
then look at that do you laughing gear
in there the end was gonna be a bit of
Hawking away whiskey it's all good
champion kiss Jade thanks fine